why do so many of the indigenous
cultures of the colder regions of north
america
seem to share the same legend a legend
that tells of a monster
that lurks in the forests bringing cold
and death to any that made it
this creature is an omen of famine a
territorial beast that preys on human
beings
some cultures describe it as an unholy
abomination
a spirit of winter and a warning against
the dangers of selfishness
one that is created whenever a person
resorts to cannibalism in order to
survive
it will gladly devour any man woman or
child that wanders into its territory
holding a horrifying and insatiable
hunger for human flesh
so how did so many cultures end up with
the same story
could it be because it's real
depictions of the beast vary but it is
most commonly recognized by its tall
skeletal form
like a body exhumed from the grave even
carrying the stench of death and decay
with it anyone who encounters one risks
being eaten or transformed into a
creature
just like it the monster's name means an
evil spirit that devours mankind
though to even say the name is taboo as
it's believed to give power to the beast
of course these are all just legends
right
stories to warn against the dangers of
greed and selfishness but otherwise
nothing to fear
there's no proof that such a beast could
actually be roaming the frozen wastes
many at the scp foundation felt the same
way
until they heard about scp-323
the wendigos skull kept under lock and
key by the foundation with
around-the-clock surveillance
scp-323 is an anomalous object with ties
to the various wendigo legends
as the object's moniker suggests scp-323
is a skull
not a human skull mind you it more
closely resembles a cervid skull
cervids are a family of mammals that
include most varieties of deer
elk and other similar animals and this
particular cervid skull sports a tall
pair of antlers
scp-323 is definitely not a fresh skull
either
it shows signs of weathering and a few
scars across the surface
looking as if the bone has been bleached
and eroded through exposure to the
elements
the skull is also missing its lower jaw
and has a sizeable hole
on the rear underside that may have been
carved using stone
tools scp-323 is kept restrained inside
an armored container within a concrete
containment cell
and personnel are only ever allowed nira
to check the restraints for signs of
damage
additionally any foundation staff that
enter scp-323 cell must be accompanied
by an armed security officer
and in the event of their containment
breach the entire site is to be
evacuated
seems like a lot of precautions and
safety measures for an old piece of bone
surely a harmless deer skull could never
be that dangerous
right wrong you might be forgiven for
thinking that a skull can't possibly
cause harm
after all scp-323 is just a skull
then whatever animal it belongs to is
dead but this skull
is far more than it appears to be
through extensive testing
the scp foundation's researchers have
learned that the skull
isn't dead no this skull
is awake and aware it can see
hear and has a sense of touch and it can
and will react to various stimuli
however this does not necessarily mean
that scp-323 is alive or even
sentient but it definitely appears to
have some level of
sapience it will target certain members
of personnel that get too close
and has attempted multiple times to
breach containment
it also reacts violently to anyone
speaking english or french
near it the only two languages
prohibited inside
scp-323 cell so while the skull is not
technically alive
it is definitely aware still why the
need for so many protocols to keep it
contained
it's not as if a skull can just walk off
on its own
of course not but scp-323 can
move at least to a certain degree often
in a reactionary manner scp-323 will
vibrate or move
on its own for example turning to watch
his personnel enter its containment cell
in most cases these movements are tiny
and insignificant
but other times the skull lunges
launching itself at foundation personnel
as it desperately tries to get free
now you know why it's kept restrained
so we have an antlered service goal that
can move and has a low level of
awareness
on their own these would be more than
enough to warrant the foundation's
interest
but the anomalous properties of scp-323
don't stop there
the skull has an inherent ability to
influence the minds of those around it
anyone spending an hour within a 15
meter radius of scp-323 is likely to
experience the effects of this
influential power this will often result
in them
exhibiting uncharacteristic behaviors
thoughts and urges
including cannibalistic tendencies and
outbursts of random violence
almost three-quarters of people that
suffer the influence of scp-323 will
feel an
overwhelming compulsion to take the
wendigo skull and
fit their heads into the chiseled hole
on the rear underside
if someone attempting this finds that
their head is too big to fit inside the
hollow skull
there have been cases of individuals
trying to bludgeon their heads on any
hard surface they can find nearby
in an attempt to get their head down to
a more manageable size
this will continue until one of three
outcomes occurs
one the person manages to fit their head
into the skull
two they cause themselves so much
cranial damage that they are rendered
unconscious
or three they end up killing themselves
through repeated violent head trauma
of course if a person actually manages
to fit their head inside scp-323
then that is a different story entirely
in these instances the individual
becomes classified as an instance of
scp-323-1
within 10 minutes of wearing the skull
this person will suffer dramatic changes
to their body
any and all body fat will be rapidly
shed as their hair also begins to fall
out
leaving them looking starved and almost
skeletal in appearance
their distal phalanges those are the
bones at the tip of the fingers
will elongate and rupture the skin as
they become bony claw-like appendages
the subject will also find that their
teeth have grown abnormally long and
sharp
while their limbs will blacken as if
they were suffering frostbite
symptoms along with their external
transformations
scp-323-1 will also get increased
strength and heightened resistance to
pain
they aren't invulnerable though and can
still sustain damage and injuries
scp-323 will also have a dramatic change
happen to their metabolism
which will occur a few minutes into the
physical transformation
the subject will now need an almost
constant intake of calories
which if they don't receive will cause
them to starve
almost instantly with the transformation
process complete
the new instance of scp-323-1 has
finally become
the wendigo a terrifying monster with
one goal
to feed the scp-323 instance will seek
out
any human beings it can find so that it
can feed upon their flesh
those who have witnessed the 323
instance in the midst of a feeding
frenzy have described the way
it violently slaughtered any person it
could find leaving only a mess of blood
as it devoured them
their screams mixed in with the sounds
of bones crunching
in the times that the creature cannot
find a human to nourish its monstrous
appetite
it will try to keep itself alive any way
it can
sometimes it will slow down its movement
to try and conserve energy
other times it will ration whatever food
is available to it
saving some of its last meal for a
leftover snack
and on occasion the monster will engage
in auto cannibalism
a form of cannibalism that involves
eating parts
of itself humans certainly seem to be
its preferred food source though
even when other sources of meat would be
easier to acquire
scp-323-1 will zero in on human beings
and will do anything it can to make a
person its next
meal when chasing down its prey human or
otherwise scp-323-1 has been observed
uttering phrases either spoken in the
primary language
of whoever was transformed by the skull
or in the severn ojibwe potawatomi
and cree languages these are all native
languages of the numerous indigenous
creatures that shared legends
of the wendigo where do the phrases come
from though
are they another side effect of
scp-323's influence
or do they originate from the skull
itself the foundation's researchers are
still trying to figure that out
and at the moment they have no clues as
to where they come
from in one containment breach in 2006
during which an instance of scp-323-1
was able to kill and devour 12 members
of foundation personnel
on-site surveillance recorded audio of
the creature speaking
it rasp while dragging a body behind it
after this the sound of a wet cracking
noise was recorded
possibly one of the victim's bones being
broken by scp-323-1
so it could get to the marrow inside the
323-1 instance does at times seem to try
and resist the influence of the wendigo
skull
additional recordings capture the
creature saying
the creature then said followed by
noises of it eating the body
that's right it seems that even the
wendigo
has its own internal struggles perhaps
showing that there is still something
left of the human who put on the skull
and that deep down they are fighting
against their cannibalistic
impulses but where exactly did the
foundation find scp-323
and is it really the skull of an actual
wendigo
the famous creature from north american
legend in 1997
the scp foundation sent a detachment to
bittern lake in saskatchewan canada
there had been reports of a local
community murdering individuals and
leaving their bodies in the forest to
appease a dangerous creature
residing nearby this creature as it was
later discovered
was an instance of scp-323-1
someone had found the skull and
succumbed to its influence
placing it on their head and turning
into a monster
ever since the locals had been killing
people and offering up their dead bodies
as sustenance
fearful of what would happen if they
didn't after being brought up with
legends of the wendigo
scp foundation agents were able to
capture the beast however died of
starvation while being transported back
to containment
they also covered up the recent deaths
in the area by giving the local
residents amnesics
and creating a cover story about an
unidentified serial killer
prior to this james namagoose a local
man who was involved in the murders was
brought
in for questioning he remained oddly
calm when interviewed
but admitted he had helped move the
bodies that were being offered up as
food for scp-323-1
or as he called it the wendigo according
to james
a local story among the cree people told
of men who had once tried to control a
wendigo
and perhaps even tame it through
offerings of food
whether or not james and his fellow
locals had the same intention
their primary concern was keeping
themselves safe he described first
encountering the creature
a warp man walking out of the woods
killed our friends right in front of us
sometimes it would stare more than it
would make to kill
try to talk to you it whispered at me
pay me
come and eat it made me cold in my bones
as the interview continued
james claimed that he felt like he
understood this warped man
he described feeling like the wendigo
was encouraging him to kill
that the creature would help him pass
when his own time came
james told the foundation doctor
questioning him that he had heard the
creature in his mind
and he felt it watching him almost
constantly mr namagu stated that he
hoped in killing people as offerings to
the wendigo
that his own family would be spared like
the other locals
james namagoose was given amnestics to
forget all about the creature
and the murders he'd played a part in
committing so far none of the
foundation's staff had
experienced any similar behavioral
effects to those james described
those who work closely with scp-323 or
have witnessed an
instance of scp-323-1 have felt the
creature communicating with them
or urging them to kill on its behalf
ultimately who is to say of scp-323 is
the skull of a wendigo like those from
legends
it certainly seems like it is but with
no way to tell exactly how old the skull
is
perhaps it's actually the reverse and it
was the wendigo legend that spawned from
instances of scp-323-1 that were first
encountered by indigenous north american
cultures hundreds of years ago
one thing is for certain if you ever
come across a skull with tall antlers
you should try to resist putting it on
otherwise you might not be feeling like
yourself for much longer
now go check out scp-3166 monster
garfield attacks gorfield
and scp-2317 the devourer of worlds
adore to another world
for more monstrous scps that'll haunt
your dreams